¿Sabías que Estados Unidos es ya la mayor
potencia energética del planeta?
Sí, así es, a día de hoy Estados Unidos
ha recobrado la posición de mayor productor
mundial de combustibles fósiles.
Ningún otro país, ni siquiera Rusia o Arabia
Saudita se acercan al gigante norteamericano.
Toda esta revolución está teniendo importantes
consecuencias y está cambiando la política
de este país.
En este vídeo te lo contamos.
Hace apenas ocho años, tan sólo ocho años,
el suministro de petróleo y gas natural ocupaba
un lugar muy destacado entre las preocupaciones
de Estados Unidos sobre su futuro.
Y… no penséis que era algo nuevo, para
nada, venía siendo dependiente del petróleo
extranjero desde hacía décadas.
Según se decía entonces, la mismísima “seguridad
nacional” dependía mucho,
muchísimo, de poder garantizar todo el suministro
de gas natural y petróleo necesario
para el poder económico e industrial del país.
Y ojo, porque esto no parecía una misión
precisamente sencilla.
Por aquel entonces, amigos de VisualPolitik,
lo recordaréis bien, el mundo parecía enfrentarse
al inminente declive de los combustibles fósiles.
Fijaos si no lo que ocurría en Estados Unidos.
(Desde principios de la década de los 70,
las reservas de petróleo de EEUU se reducían
año tras año, la producción se había desplomado
un 50%, que se dice pronto, e incluso la producción
de gas natural también caía).
En otras palabras, Estados Unidos estaba agotando
a toda velocidad sus recursos energéticos
y se exponía a depender de suministradores
que a ojos de los responsables de la seguridad
nacional eran, como decirlo…, poco fiables.
Hablamos de países como Arabia Saudí, Rusia
o Nigeria, por ejemplo.
Sin embargo, desde entonces las cosas han
cambiado bastante, y como tantas otras veces
los pronósticos nunca se cumplieron y hoy
los tanques de almacenamiento de crudo a lo
largo y ancho del mundo están a rebosar.
¿Qué está ocurriendo?
Veámoslo.
EL REGRESO DE UNA POTENCIA PETROLERA
En los últimos años Estados Unidos ha vivido
toda una revolución energética.
En pocos años la producción de petróleo
casi se ha duplicado y hoy las reservas que
se pueden explotar garantizan el suministro
por muchos años.
Fijaos en este gráfico del Wall Street Journal,
nos muestra el incremento de la producción
de petróleo en EEUU desde 2011.
(Como os podéis imaginar, que Estados Unidos
casi haya duplicado su producción tiene mucho
que ver con la enorme caída que el precio
del petróleo ha registrado desde 2014).
Y no solo ha sido el petróleo, podemos decir
que prácticamente lo mismo ha ocurrido con
el gas natural, así que hoy Estados Unidos
es el mayor productor mundial de ambos recursos.
El caso es que como podéis imaginar todo
esto tiene consecuencias en muchos frentes
diferentes.
(Pero… ¿Qué ha ocurrido para que se produzca
semejante boom?
Pues, como muchos sabéis todo este cambio
se ha debido a una evolución tecnológica
conocida como Fracking, una tecnología que,
aunque se conoce desde hace décadas no ha
sido viable económicamente hasta hace relativamente
poco tiempo).
[Antes de nada, el fracking es una técnica
muy controvertida y de momento sólo se utiliza
para producir petróleo a gran escala en cuatro
países: Estados Unidos, Canadá, Rusia y
Argentina.
Al final del vídeo y también en la descripción
os dejo un enlace donde podéis ver cómo
funciona.
En su defensa hay que decir que muchos de
sus problemas tienen que ver con que es una
tecnología relativamente nueva.
A medida que se va utilizando y desarrollando
su impacto se está reduciendo.
En cualquier caso, ese es un tema que trataremos
otro día.
En este vídeo nos vamos a centrar en sus
consecuencias económicas y también políticas.]
ALIMENTANDO EL MOTOR ECONÓMICO
Amigos, el renacer petrolero de EEUU ha tenido mucho que ver en la recuperación económica de
este país en los últimos años.
Por un lado, las importaciones de petróleo
de EEUU se han reducido bastante y claro siguiendo
la ley de la oferta y la demanda, toda esta
oferta adicional de petróleo ha provocado
que bajen los precios, así que EEUU importa
menos petróleo y este mucho es más barato.
Y como sabéis, petróleo más barato supone
gasolina más barata.
(Pues bien, se calcula que solo por este efecto
los consumidores estadounidenses se ahorran
150.000 millones de dólares al año.
Dinero que por supuesto se utiliza para consumir
otros productos, para montar negocios, para
prestarlos, etc, etc).
Pero, cuidado, aquí no acaba todo ni de lejos.
Petróleo y gas más barato favorece también
a la industria, especialmente a una, a la
que además de utilizar energía, utiliza
estos dos recursos como materia prima.
Me refiero a la industria petroquímica, la
que, por ejemplo, produce el plástico o el
PVC entre otras muchas cosas.
Pues bien, la combinación de mucho petróleo
disponible garantía de suministro y bajos
precios está impulsando un boom industrial
en el sector petroquímico de Estados Unidos.
Atentos a las magnitudes, porque son de aúpa:
(El sector petroquímico está desarrollando
proyectos por valor de 185.000 millones de
dólares solo en Estados Unidos.
En 2016 este tipo de proyectos representaron
casi el 50% de toda la inversión industrial
en el país.
Todas estas inversiones convertirán a Estados
Unidos en un gran exportador de plásticos).
Ojo, amigos, para que os hagáis una idea,
se espera que, en pocos años las exportaciones
netas de productos petroquímicos como plásticos,
pero también fertilizantes o disolventes,
superen los 110.000 millones de dólares al
año.
Esto es casi tanto como todo el petróleo
que exporta Arabia Saudita.
Desde luego, amigos, semejante negocio ayudará
mucho a reducir el déficit comercial de Estados
Unidos, ese del que tanto se queja Donald
Trump.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque aún queda
más.
(En diciembre de 2015, como ya no era una
prioridad en materia de Seguridad Nacional,
el Congreso de Estados Unidos levantó la
prohibición que existía sobre la exportación
de Gas Natural y Petróleo).
Pues bien, Estados Unidos está a punto de
convertirse en un exportador neto de Gas Natural,
y además, está previsto que, en 2017 venda
de media, 1 millón de barriles de petróleo
al día.
Tal como lo escucháis.
A ver, Estados Unidos, aunque mucho menos
que antes, sigue comprando petróleo del extranjero,
pero en este negocio muchos países por diferentes
motivos, como por ejemplo para mejorar la
seguridad energética diversificando sus fuentes
están dispuestos a pagar una prima, y las
empresas de Estados Unidos se aprovechan de
ello.
(Pero sin duda alguna donde más se nota es
en el gas.
Hasta hace poco transportar el gas era algo
difícil y se necesitaban enormes gasoductos,
pero ahora gracias a la tecnología del Gas
Natural Licuado se transporta prácticamente
como el petróleo, en grandes barcos).
El gas así suministrado supone ya casi la
mitad de todo el mercado mundial, y aquí
las empresas estadounidenses están en primera
línea.
Menos importaciones, exportaciones de gas,
reflorecimiento en la industria… me parece
que a los Estados Unidos eso del proteccionismo
de Trump le pilla en mal momento.
Y, esperad un segundo, porque esta revolución
energética también tiene consecuencias políticas.
UN SALTO DIPLOMÁTICO
No se puede entender la política internacional
de Estados Unidos en los últimos años sin
prestar atención al impacto que ha tenido
esta revolución energética.
Me explico, hasta ahora como el suministro
de petróleo era una prioridad de la Seguridad
Nacional, Oriente Medio y los países productores
jugaban un papel muy relevante en la agenda
estadounidense.
(Pero el nuevo empuje petrolero de Estados
Unidos ha hecho que las prioridades de la
seguridad nacional cambien y con ellas la
política exterior, que ahora puede, por ejemplo,
centrarse en Asia, una tierra que como bien
sabéis los suscriptores de VisualPolitik,
es la gran mina de oportunidades).
Tal es así, amigos, que si no hubiese sido
por este cambio de prioridades, probablemente
Obama nunca hubiese decidido retirar las tropas
de Irak; probablemente la situación en Yemen,
Libia o Siria hubiese sido diferente…
Pero, digámoslo claro, todo esto del petróleo
árabe y la política del golfo ya no es tan
importante para Estados Unidos que incluso
se da el lujo de impulsar la llamada OTAN
árabe, que viene a ser algo así como, vale,
os encargáis de vuestra seguridad y nosotros
solamente os echamos una mano… por eso de
no correr el riesgo de crear una crisis mundial.
(Por supuesto esta mayor independencia energética
también le da a Washington la oportunidad
de ser más exigentes con las petromonarquías
del golfo pérsico por ejemplo en materia
de derechos humanos.
Que aproveche o no esa oportunidad, ya depende
de la estrategia política de cada gobierno).
Por cierto, si algo está claro es que con
Trump en la Casa Blanca la apuesta por el
fracking es total.
El nuevo Presidente quiere continuar el trabajo
de Obama, pero metiendo la quinta, eliminando
cualquier obstáculo que pueda haber por el
camino.
PRIMERO, LA ENERGIA AMERICANA
Donald Trump lo tiene claro, lo prometió
en la campaña y lo ha reiterado con palabras
y hechos desde que ocupa el Despacho Oval:
su prioridad es dar vía libre al desarrollo
petrolero y gasista.
(Entre otras cosas ha prometido eliminar muchas
de las normas y controles aprobados por Obama
que podrían frenar esta actividad.
Trump, amigos de VisualPolitik, quiere que
el petróleo barato y abundante sea el ingrediente
principal de su receta).
Y dicho y hecho, porque Trump se ha rodeado
en los puestos clave de gente bastante vinculada
al petróleo.
(Cómo Secretario de Estado, Trump apostó
por Rex Tillerson, que antes era el mismisimo
CEO de la Exxon-Mobil.
Al frente del departamento de Energía
está Rick Perry, una persona muy ligada al
sector del petróleo y que fue gobernador
de Texas, el estado petrolero por excelencia.
Y para rematar la faena, al frente de la Agencia
de Protección Ambiental está Scott Pruitt,
exprocurador general de Oklahoma, otro estado
petrolero y también con buenas relaciones
con el sector).
En fin, esta es la particular revolución
que está viviendo Estados Unidos, una revolución
que ha hecho saltar por los aires todo el
poder de la OPEP.
Cómo toda novedad tecnológica, es evidente
que el fracking tiene riesgos, pero también
es evidente que es una tecnología que ha
llegado para quedarse, que está provocando
muchas cosas buenas y que a medida que se
desarrolle será más segura.
Eso sí, hasta que llegue ese momento, los
controles medioambientales son esenciales.
Turno para ti, ¿Crees que esta revolución
energética de Estados Unidos es el comienzo
de una la nueva era del petróleo barato?
Puedes dejarnos tu opinión en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y asegúrate
de estar suscrito al canal para estar al tanto
de todas nuestras novedades.
Por cierto, en este vídeo te contamos más
cosas sobre el mundo del petróleo y la OPEP.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.